-I want to ask this -- You know,
and, again,
we can't talk about when you
and your colleagues talk about
cases that are before
the Supreme Court.
But I think one thing that's
fascinating to
people like myself who don't
understand the workings
of the court -- what do yo
talk about when you're on break?
What do you talk about --
Is it true that
you have lunch together?
-After every argument and afte
every conference on Friday
And what do other people
talk about
when they're not talking
about business?
The movies, books, the family,
whose child is behaving
and who child is misbehaving
We talk like anyone else.
-When you talk about movies,
is it always that
five people like it
and four don't?
Do you ever -- Are there eve
unanimous opinions on movies
-Well, for a different reason,
there isn't.
There are some people
on the court
who don't really look at movies.
-Yeah, right.
-And there are other
people on the court,
like one of my colleagues
who speaks French --
So, when he's seen a
French movie, I can't watch it
and tell him whether I
like it or not.
-I see.
-So --- But, no, not --
Thankfully, not all of us
watch the same movies.
-That's good.
That's probably,
I would say, for the best.
You -- Ask really quick.
You know, obviously,
Ruth Bader Ginsburg --
an iconic figure.
She had some
health scares this year.
She is back. How's she doing
And is it -- Is she
a good colleague to have?
-She's a wonderful
colleague to have.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Every step of the way, for me,
that I've been on the court,
Justice Ginsburg
has been there to welcome me
from my very first day there
where she lent me --
or gave me -- a copy of he
bench manual that tells yo
how she runs her chambers
so I didn't have to
start from scratch, to the tim
I issued my first opinion
and she sent me a note telling
me what a fine opinion it was,
to everything else that she does
to help my life
there on the court.
And she's an amazing, brave,
woman -- and strong.
I call her "The Steel Magnolia."
-Oh, that's very nice.
-Delicate on the outside, bu
she has an iron rod behind her
-Well, thank you so much
for being here.
-Thank you.
-And I wish the best to yo
and all your colleagues.
-Thank you.
-And this is Justice
Sonia Sotomayor, everybody